welcome everyone welcome to the Mars
lecture on business ethics this is a
signature event of the ethics politics
and economics major made possible by the
generosity of Forrest Mars who wanted
Yale to stand at the forefront of
thinking about the importance of ethics
and all walks of life including and
perhaps especially in business and today
to help us elevate our thinking we are
so fortunate to have with us one of the
most interesting and significant figures
in British politics today as a member of
parliament for the last nine years
Rory Stewart has served in ministerial
roles including most recently as
Secretary of State for international
development and perhaps I will leave it
at that and let mr. Stewart tell us
about some interesting events about
which you probably know but what
happened to his cabinet position when he
decided to challenge mr. Boris Johnson
over the brexit issue and over the
leadership of the Tory party and let me
tell you just a little bit about his
remarkable and diverse career so you
will know if you don't already know how
lucky we are to happen it with us today
born in Hong Kong two British diplomatic
family mr. Stuart grew up in Malaysia
and in Scotland and after graduating
from Oxford he served as an
infantry officer before joining himself
joining the British diplomatic corps
he served in Indonesia and I understand
before the age of thirty became the
British representative to Montenegro
following the Kosovo campaign later he
was a deputy governor for the Coalition
Provisional Authority in Iraq and during
his many soldiers abroad including that
one
he has written vivid funny memorable
books beginning with the places in
between which is a book about his Trek
on foot across Afghanistan in the
company of only Bob or a dog that he
picked up along the way
delightful book I recommend it to you
all but we're even more delighted that
Rory Stewart has made the trek to Yale
today please join me in welcoming him
rusty thank you very very much indeed
for coming are you able to hear me
clearly I have a microphone on which
should make it audible um I've taken
rather seriously and solemnly the fact
that this is a lecture on business
ethics and I'm going to be talking
mostly around the theme of business
ethics I'm very comfortable very happy
answering questions afterwards and
anything you want to ask me on if you
want to talk about brexit or Boris I'm
very happy to go in that direction but I
feel that I feel that I at least owe the
the generosity of the Mars family and
this very generous lecture to
concentrate on the theme with which we
begin which is the theme of business
ethics and in particular I want to talk
about one of the great themes of the
modern age which is the role that the
private sector can play in international
development probably potentially the
greatest moral cause available to
business in the private sector which is
its role in achieving development and
this has become a more and more popular
theme through a series of and these are
quite sort of
kradic moments but through a series of
conferences in 2002 and 2012 2015 which
eventually ended up in the grand phrase
which some of you may be familiar with
which is billions into trillions so the
fundamental idea is that the needs of
the developing world to achieve the
sustainable development goals which are
these these goals set out in this
multilateral framework by 2030 involve
on average an investment of an
additional 2.5 trillion dollars a year
now obviously these numbers are to some
extent plucked out of the air I mean the
the the UN statisticians will will not
be very grateful to me saying this
they've put a lot of effort into trying
to generate this figure of two and a
half trillion but by and large this is
an attempt to put a number on the amount
of money you would need in order to
fulfill the infrastructure objectives
which would come in an additional sort
of 500 billion a year the needs on
things like water which would require
about a hundred billion a year needs on
education and health which are about 150
billion level all the needs in
telecommunications which are about 300
billion a year etc accession and to put
the problem in context the total
contributions of the domestic domestic
expenditure of these countries and the
overseas development assistance in other
words the money that would come from the
US government or the World Bank or the
IMF for the British government
barely approaches 1.2 trillion a year so
the the total amount required has more
than double the amount that's already
going in we're barely contributing 1/3
of what would be required to meet this
in fact it's even more extreme than that
if you look at the British government a
British government currently spends 0.7%
of our gross national income on
international development it's required
by law that was a target set we are
barely contributing one
400th of the amount of money that would
be required so myself a sexually safe
international island I felt very smug I
said an office I controlled twenty
billion dollars a year of expenditure
that seems like an enormous amount of
money to British taxpayers it is an
enormous amount of money but in terms of
finding that additional 2.5 trillion
dollars a year it's not a great deal of
money right which leads me to this
rather grisly stuff up on the board
right now III have to begin essentially
by pointing out that one of the reasons
why it's very difficult talking about
these subjects difficult about how you
actually translate two and a half
trillion required private sector money
into really making lives better in
Malawi lives better in Jordan lives
better in leisure or Chad right how do
you translate all this chat and all this
money into somebody actually completing
seven years of education a girl
completing seven years of education in
Michelle or how do we actually get clean
water to someone in Lake Turkana in
Kenya one of the reasons it's difficult
to talk about is that we are trapped in
an incredibly abstract world of jargon
and that's what I'm largely indicating
on this slide behind me there is
absolutely no requirement to look at
this in any detail this thing this
spaghetti bowl that they've created
right is complete nonsense if you were
to spend any time actually looking
seriously at this what it basically
tells you is that there are about four
different ways of giving money to other
people right you can give them the money
in a grant you can lend them the money
through debts you can make an equity
investment or you can provide some form
of insurance instrument or you can have
a hybrid instrument which is basically
just a way of combining all those things
and on the left-hand side there are
different people who give the money
right again no big surprises the
different people could be a country like
the United Kingdom and its aid could be
a multilateral agency like the World
Bank could be a philanthropist or it
could be various forms of private sector
investment quite why somebody believes
that in the OECD that illustrating it in
that way would really help you I'm not
quite sure right and then up at the top
you have those of you who can't read it
you you're looking here at the absolute
epitome of everything that is wrong in
the way that we think about
international developments so um in the
increasingly globalizing interdependent
world economy a holistic approach to the
interconnected national international
and systemic challenges of finite sum
development sustainable gender sensitive
people centered development in all parts
the globe is essential such an approach
will open up opportunity thrall and help
to ensure that resources are create and
used effectively and that strong
accountable institutions there are
established all levels to that end
collective and coherent actions needed
each interrelated area of our data
involving all stakeholders in active
partnership right ok enough enough of
all of that you're going to take this
away can I try to terms
so let me just quickly work my way along
this whiteboard right the first point is
why the private sector and International
Development and I've given one answer to
begin with right which is that we need
the money
we need approximately 2.5 trillion a
year extra and that money exists at the
moment in places like the city of London
it exists in companies if you're looking
for that kind of money to go
international development the obvious
place to look is the private sector yes
sorry here we got never try this look
does that work or maybe not right here
look how about that does that work we
got another one coming ok not another
marker inbound I'll keep talking well
the marker it comes in so first reason
scale right you need to go the private
side to get money second reason why you
go to the private sector the private
sector is very good at doing certain
kinds of things which really matter to
development so 90% of jobs of jobs
created in Africa at the moment are
created through the private sector thank
you very much I didn't try these as well
see how this goes okay ah look at that
beautiful so number one the quantum
number two the things that the private
sector is very good at doing jobs number
three an assumption that the private
sector may because of various mechanisms
for example competitive market
mechanisms be slightly better sometimes
their development agencies or charities
at choosing projects that can be
sustained what do I mean by that
maybe the profit motive of the private
sector means that they look a little bit
more closely before they make an
investment into a particular business in
Kenya and whether there really is a
market for those Goods and if they get
it right hopefully thank you very much
indeed
just first that's lovely thank you
hopefully if they get that investment
right then the jobs can be sustained
into the future right so potentially
good investments
finally very very important in this
whole narrative about the private sector
getting involved in international
development is that the recipient
countries do not want to feel like their
charity cases they do not want to feel
that they are victims who are just
receiving handouts from aid agencies if
you are the president of Kenya or the
other president Democratic Republic of
Congo you want to feel that you're a
partner that somebody is making a viable
business investment so a lot of the
rhetoric coming out of sub-saharan
Africa is about partnering on a business
investment and employment but right the
big but the big part is that actually
this entire process has not really
worked in fact I would go further since
we began this process of trying to turn
billions into trillions instead of
actually increasing the amount of
private-sector investment going into
developing countries the amount of
private-sector investment going to in
developing countries has fallen very
sharply and in 20 between 2017 and 2018
foreign direct investment going into
developing countries reduced by 30
percent the first trimester of 2018
project-based investment alone dropped
by 30 percent
now this has caused a real problem for
people why is it failing oh okay back to
the blue thank you very much thank you
that's a that's an interesting it's a
sort of symbol I failed and I'm writing
about failure
now the model was supposed to be that
the way to get private-sector investment
into developing countries is what I'm
going to open up to the audience to wake
you up all right what are the kind of
things that people think about when they
want to think about getting private
sector investment into developing
countries what might you do to increase
it the other billions into trillions
there's all this money sitting in New
York and learn you want to get it in
what absolutely right okay that's the
first thing you do a risk guarantee some
form of guarantee mechanism something
else yeah quite right yeah okay you
might try to focus on creating an
enabling environment for business let's
get some examples of what you might want
an enabling environment to encourage
investment coming into these countries
yup open up the markets yeah so we're
going to open these markets we might
what might you encourage the government
of that country to do to try to get the
investment in what other things yeah you
might get the infrastructure try to get
in to invest in infrastructure so for
example if you're trying to get somebody
to go into Afghanistan in order to
exploit the fact that Afghanistan has
very good fruit very good apricots very
good peaches that's not going to work
unless you've got roads to get it out
and unless you've got some facilities in
order to dry or freeze the fruit in
order to leave it otherwise everything
gets bruised on the truck and all your
fruit gets ruined sir minimize
corruption
corruption the rule of law yep
security somebody said right another
thing that you often put pressure on
governments for is - yep tax regime very
good
however notwithstanding attempts to do
all this kind of stuff we actually have
this 30% reduction in a single year in
the amount of foreign direct investment
going in now
let me now begin to sketch out I'm gonna
try a different color if it doesn't work
tell me no good nope okay all right
rubbish okay I'll try the back oh my god
is this is this a bit more visible no
all right I'll stick with blue okay it's
a blue and black okay very good okay so
what are the fundamental problems
fundamental problems let's just run
through a few of them problem number one
is a problem that is not the right pen
problem number one is a problem of scale
I mean simply the amount of money that
you're talking about trying to move into
these countries is inconceivable I mean
trying to go from billions to trillions
is an incredible ask right second
problem investable projects so if you
take the british development finance
organization cdc which was given four
billion pounds in order to make
investments specifically targeted at
developing countries they haven't been
able to spend the money right it's very
very difficult for them to find
investments at the moment in africa in
particular where they're targeted we
actually allows them to put their money
in and get any kind of money back in
fact the more pressure that has been put
on CDC to spend that money the more
money they're losing and that's only
four billion we're not talking trillions
there that's actually finding where to
put that four billion CDC the third
problem is trying to understand context
and in particular politics and conflict
let me here take an example of Jordan
and I'm taking Jordan quite deliberately
because Jordan is not theoretically one
of the difficult countries in the world
right it isn't a place like Chad or
Nazaire right Nazir at the moment the
fertility rate is about seven children
per family right these are countries
where poverty is so extreme the climatic
pressures are so extreme it's very very
difficult to know what to do
Jordan is not one of those countries
Jordan's a middle-income country right
Jordan is a country where the incomes
are not on the hundreds of dollars a
year it's in the thousands of dollars a
year in which literacy rates are up at
ninety percent but even in somewhere
like Jordan it's very difficult to do
things let me give you one example of an
ideal example of ethical business
investment in Jordan solar-power Jordan
should be the ideal place to put solar
power actually it's not just the
sunlight the atmosphere in Jordan
particularly northern Jordan ideally
placed for putting in solar panels the
prices have fallen very dramatically at
a single installation in Jordan which
four years ago would have been
generating power at eighteen point five
cents is now generating at two point
three cents it's unbelievably drop in
the cost right they're now generating
energy in Jordan for a much lower price
than they can generate energy from any
other source because the quality of the
air in the sunlight but it is completely
impossible
to convince anybody to invest in putting
an additional solar capacity in Jordan
why is this alright does anyone want to
try to get into what could be the
problem here so we have an ideal
proposition we have beautiful sunlight a
wonderful ethical business proposal and
if we could get it right in Jordan for
goodness sake we're going to go off to
the Sahel we're gonna do it in de share
we're going to do it in Chad where
there's a lot of sunlight to moving a
running solar panels all over the world
to generate energy why isn't it
happening anybody suggest one problem
Jordan sir okay so this gentleman is 100
percent right okay the government has
already made three major investments
over the last ten years in burning a
very very expensive shale oil and verus
and imported LNG and they already have
contracts for that on providing
electricity which far exceeds their
current demand and the contracts that
they've signed are such that they are
compelled to pay five hundred million
dollars a year to these companies
regardless of whether or not they
actually take any electricity from these
companies right but why did they do that
why did they get into signing these
extraordinary crazy diverse contracts 30
years forward on shale oil and gas
because that's also reveals part of the
problem and business and development why
did they sign this conference here's a
clue they signed the contracts just
after the Arab Spring in 2011 okay the
answer is they were dependent on a gas
pipeline from Egypt that was blown up 12
times and terrorist attacks in 2011 and
they concluded at the beginning of 2012
that they needed to diversify their
supply so they signed these incredibly
expensive contracts with shell and
others for shale oil and imported LNG in
order to have a diversified by and not
be exposed
now they're tied in for 25 years all
right so what is the alternative thing
that you might be able to do with all
this lovely land where you can generate
solar power and Jordan
if there isn't a domestic requirement
for it what might you want to do with it
okay you can't leave there's no no
domestic demand in Jordan but his sell
it sell it to another country right okay
what's the problem there what's the
problem that Jordan faces selling it to
another country okay so their markets
they've got great markets that actually
want that power right there's demand and
Lebanon there's demand in Iraq and
there's demand and Turkey for that power
they could sell to all three of those
countries but you've got to get it there
and sitting in the middle is Syria all
the transmission lines go straight the
way through Syria so you can't export
either so this is just one example right
I'm just using Jordan as an example but
you can imagine that if I now move on to
what seems on the surface the incredible
potential in Africa in particular for
the generation of solar power which
theoretically you could cover the whole
Sahara Desert in photovoltaic cells why
is it that that isn't really happening
why is the billions not being turned
into trillions in the generation
capacity not being built right the
entire additional capacity brought on in
Africa over the decade leading up to
2017 was 6,000 megawatts right it's tiny
tiny amount of additional capacity six
gigawatts of capacity to put that in
context over a decade they built less
than 8% of the current UK generating
capacity for the whole ourselves that
are in Africa and I'll get into trying
to talk through a particular project in
Kenya to try to illustrate how this goes
wrong but the point is that there we
have an example even in rather an easy
middle-income country like Jordan let
alone
Oh Chad y-you can't really get that okay
next sorry
apologies there's a real comedy going on
with the Pens here you know given that
my whole talk is about competence and
practicality and I'm completely unable
to pick up the right pen there's a
something some sort of lesson you need
to draw here about the gap between
rhetoric and reality and the so politics
okay it's very very tempting when we
talk about the role of the private
sector the role of business in making
ethical investments and addressing some
of the great challenges of our time such
as for example the challenge of climate
change
to imagine that there are lovely neat
financial technical solutions which can
be brought to bear now I've talked of
course about the most extreme cases in
the developing world in which conflict
and war and instability makes that very
very difficult but of course actually if
you bring it closer to home and look at
a country like Britain you actually
understand that even in Britain it's
very difficult to get the private sector
to go into some of these areas I'm going
to pause on this and just say that if
any of these nice people who want there
are lots of seats and I would like to
invite you down can you bear to come
down anybody or do you want to slip away
anybody want to come down they can come
down this many many seats so if anybody
would like to come down so let's take
the example of climate resilience in
Britain right Britain is beginning to
experience like many other countries
more and more flooding and in the recent
events in 2014-2015 we began for the
first time to experience unprecedented
rainfall seventeen inches of rain
hillsides being washed away thousands of
communities getting flooded and these
were things which the Met Office had
said were one in a hundred year events
which happened twice in a three year
period so two one
hundred year events happen twice and
Harvey appear with us reappeared now the
solution of course that ever he comes up
with particularly governments that don't
like spending money is let's bring the
private sector in to make the nice
climate resilient investment in
particular let's try to address the
problem of the government perhaps
perpetually having to bail out
householders whose houses go underwater
by doing what what's the solution that
somebody suggests was what's a good
private sector solution to the
government having to pay every time
somebody gets flooded and insurance
market right exactly so here we are in
Britain very very stable environment
very good data no war going on there
conflicts government leans in to try to
work with the insurance industry to do
this negotiates for five years and
discovers in the end that the insurance
industry is only prepared to provide
insurance for the most vulnerable houses
if the British government itself writes
a check of a hundred and eighty five
million pounds in a year to the
insurance industry to incentivize them
to do this right notwithstanding the
logic of the market which theoretically
suggests that if you just got the
premiums right the whole thing should be
able to to cover itself in addition as
you begin to get into the detail of the
government response to flooding you
begin to realize that these sort of
technocratic models the economic
technocratic models which we would try
to apply to Jordan or Nazir
don't really work when you're working
with communities on the ground in
Britain because you begin to realize
just how much local politics grinds into
the response that the allocation of
money isn't easy partly because I want
to know why you're not dealing with my
flooding and I am not at all satisfied
to be told that the reason why you're
not doing it is that you have a fair
mathematical formula that has calculated
that my flood risk and the cost of
repairing my house yeah compared with
the risk to
people in the Humber where their 150,000
people living below sea level and that
there are 125 year risk of being flooded
does not satisfy me at all nor am i at
all satisfied to hear that I don't
deserve the money because I have a one
in a hundred year risk of being flooded
when I've actually been flooded twice
since three years nor and and these
things become more and more sort of
depressing nor really am I prepared to
accept that I should be contributing
towards this flood risk in any way and
companies feel this too so again another
great attempt is to get business to
invest for example we try to get BMW to
pay for the bridge in Oxford going over
to their facility on the grounds that
they have an interest in getting their
workers there and the flood stopping
their workers getting the factory and
that's going to take money off the
bottom line so surely BMW is going to
put in 12 and a half million pounds to
help pay for the bridge well guess what
BMW has no intention right are putting
12 and a half million pounds in to pay
for the bridge right and then we get
into the question of the profit motive
which I'm going to come back to at the
end because we're talking about business
here so probably the smartest thing if
you're a Treasury official or an
economist and trying to think about
water management in any country is to
think about a privatized water system so
in Britain in theory the whole thing
sounds beautiful right we privatized our
water system in 1982 from 1982 to today
the private sector has invested 28
billion pounds in upgrading water
infrastructure water quality is 98
percent better than it was in the early
1980s Alta jiz are 95 percent down on
the cost of water in and out of your
house is 1 pound in and one pound out
what a great success right it's done
much better than the government did
except 85% of the British public is in
an absolute boiling rage right and wants
to get the private sector out of the
water industry why yes
it's a public good right so many of them
just feel that the public goods my water
I don't want private sector getting
involved what else is annoying them
right what's annoying them as these
companies are owned by hedge funds based
in New York right and they may be
providing a service but they're making
extraordinary profits and nobody wants
to be in a situation where a utility of
that sort is involved in giving people
twenty thirty million pound bonuses and
payouts and all this kind of things so
that the wonderful involvement of the
private sector and this philanthropic
activity is immediately undermined in
terms of legitimacy with the public
right let me now fast-forward to
solutions and then we can go into more
questions okay how then do we think
about the role of business in this great
moral project of international
development how do we really envisage
what a constructive role could be
notwithstanding all these problems of
scale of investable projects context of
conflict and of politics the answer I
think is two things the first is to make
sure that when we think about the
private sector investing in
international development we
contextualize it within a much broader
sphere of diplomatic and developmental
activity which reinforces what the
private sector is doing controls it
regulates it adjusts it let me give you
an example of Myanmar so Burma thinking
about the private sector and someone
like Myanmar is not just about a
question of Quantum's it's not just
about how do we turn billions into
trillions how do we get a lot of private
direct investment going into Yemma
it may be thinking about international
relations and the case of Myanmar it may
be thinking about the relationship
between Myanmar and China and in
particular the Chinese belt and road
initiative and in particular Chinese
involvement in timber logging through
oops it may be about the Chinese
construction of a port on the coast it
may be about China making soft loans to
Myanmar and the way in which the
international community can help to
advise the Burmese government and
navigate those relationships with the
Chinese government right so we're not
just talking about business on its own
we're talking about business in that
case wrapped in diplomacy
secondly we may not just be talking
about business in Myanmar we are may
also be talking about business wrapped
and technical revenue advice right so
probably the smartest single investment
made by the World Bank in Myanmar three
and a half years ago was an investment
in the revenue Authority which increased
the tax take of the country from about
11% to 12% of its GDP right that was an
investment by the World Bank of
something in the region of 10 to 15
million dollars in a bunch of tax
advisers and consultants which generated
about one and a half billion dollars a
year for the government of Myanmar next
it may be about certification so one of
the great potentials of Myanmar is of
course in its natural resources its
timber its gemstones it's rubies its
emeralds right but these are currently
controlled generally by in certain
groups gangsters illegal activities to
really get that timber to the European
markets to get those emeralds and to
Tiffany's one of the most useful things
that you can do is not simply to say
okay here is the private sector but
think about what would be involved in
some form of certification when it comes
to tourism income in Myanmar it may be
about thinking about environment
particular on the Irrawaddy there's a
lot of fishing going on a lot of fishing
going on with dynamite at the moment but
the Irrawaddy is home to the Irrawaddy
River Dolphin
the variety were for dolphin is a
extraordinary thing where you knew must
go and see it
it's might doing my part for me on my
tourism right when you go out with a
fisherman with the Irrawaddy River
dolphin the arrow out of river dolphin
indicates which direction the fisherman
is to throw the net and you can see it
sticking its head up and when the
fisherman throws in the wrong way is
shaking its head in the other direction
and generally getting infuriated with
the fisherman right and these amazing
creatures which are actually almost
unique in the world are of course under
enormous threat under enormous threat
from overfishing along the Irrawaddy a
proper response to that could both
increase officee the tourism income but
it involves a very smart approach to the
fishing industry and Irrawaddy and a
very thoughtful approach to regulation
and of course all of this needs to be
surrounded by some much more traditional
development projects which the private
sector isn't going to get involved in so
for example you might want in Myanmar to
do cash transfer programs to women in
other words you might want to simply
give twenty five dollars a month to some
of the poorest women in Myanmar because
they are likely to spend it on nutrition
for their children you might want to
employ community health workers in order
to ensure that people are taking their
tuberculosis pills right these are not
things that the private sector is likely
to do on its own
and a lot of this is about realizing
that in thinking about business and
International Development we are not
simply thinking about economic growth so
the question of whether Myanmar grows
next year by five percent or five point
five percent or four point five percent
is not really within our gift as an
international development community
right any more than really when we talk
about China's grace from 1980 to 2010 we
really were in a position to control
whether China grew at eight percent six
percent seven percent and that
extraordinary achievement in China of
dragging hundreds of millions of people
out of poverty wasn't really an
achievement driven by the World Bank or
International Development experts at all
however had we looked at China from 1980
and said is there a way of thinking
about the way in which this growth might
occur which did not involve the cutting
down of their loan and forests the air
pollution in Beijing the disruption of
the Yangtze River the elimination of
traditional communities the loss of
cultural heritage then you might begin
to get into a more interesting potential
e-naught in China because the scale of
China and the cultural issues that would
have been involved at conversation but
potentially in something like Myanmar
about a path of development which is
more sustainable which includes more
elements than simply the elimination of
extreme poverty and that brings me to my
final point which is the question of the
measurement of impact so really what I'm
getting to here is to say that what we
are not likely to get out of private
sector investments between now and 2030
is that great quantity are those
trillions but that may be what we need
to be thinking about is not the quantity
but the quality of that investment and
we need to start looking much more
closely at the different forms of
investment made for example in
sub-saharan Africa by these companies
and working out how we can measure the
social impact of that investment in the
relationship between that investment and
the sustainable development goals that
we are pursuing and realize just how
tricky that measurement is
so for example right I could be a
company that is running care homes
that's doing a very good thing it's
looking after elderly people but I could
be paying the workers in my care homes a
very very low wage right it's a bad
thing I could be a company shell BP that
is producing an enormous amount of
carbon dioxide and having a huge damage
on the on the climate but I could also
be paying a huge amounts of taxation
revenue to the government of Senegal
which is then being used to pay for
health and education in that country we
need to be very careful when we look at
these companies on what they're choosing
to report it's in again in the details
so let's say the company is saying we
are very proud about the fact that we
are have reduced by 50% the amount of
mega litres of water that we are
extracting in our process of creating
t-shirts right okay this is only really
a relevant fact if there is genuine
water stress in that country or at least
it's a much more relevant fact if there
is genuine water stress in that country
than if there isn't genuine water stress
in that country and so on and so forth
because we're also going to get into
incommensurable issues right how do you
weigh up when you talk about an ethical
sustainable investment somebody emitting
carbon against somebody using child
labour against somebody polluting a
river right these are three quite
different forms of crime they can't be
weighed on a single scale an enormous
amount of energy is now trying to go in
to guide the way in which we as
governments we as the public can work
with companies to make these ethical
investments but we need to understand
that it really depends again how we
engage with these companies are we
engaging with them as consumers or in
other words we making a choice not to
buy this particular t-shirt because of
the pollution in the river are we
engaging as investors and if we're
engaging as investors what kind of
investor are we right are we an investor
who's simply putting short-term money in
and out or are we taking an equity stake
in this company which gives us a very
different relationship to the
kind of business put all of this
together we come back to an idea that in
thinking about International Development
we need to change our model we need to
get out of the idea that there is this
date called 2030 there is the thing
billions into trillions that there is
this magic entity called the private
sector right private finance which is
going to come in turn billions into
trillions and suddenly achieves the
sustainable development goals by 2030
and instead get ourselves into a model
which is much more about partnership and
a much more complex nuanced partnership
of the sort that I was gesturing towards
in terms of this example in Myanmar at a
partnership that could be happening at a
whole series of different dimensions and
which above all needs to be driven by
the values and the pride of the people
in that country right it's extremely
important to understand that this
investment in the Irrawaddy River
Dolphin should not be my caring about
the era where a dolphin dolphin but
being confident in the fact that Burmese
citizens themselves take pride in the
fact that they have a unique a unique
species in their country that they
themselves have an interest in
protecting the teak forests that they
themselves have an interest in air
pollution that they themselves do not
want polluted water that they themselves
want to try to think about child labor
and finding in that partnership of
values a way of thinking about
international development that is not
simply about money that is not simply
about incomes that is not simply about
dragging people out of extreme poverty
but isn't about a much broader
conversation about the kind of world
that we want to live in the kind of
society we want to create above all a
vision of international development that
is about what Aristotle called
eudaimonia in other words being well and
doing well in being well thank you very
much
[Applause]
now I promised that if you want to ask
me about practice it or anything you
wanna I'm happy to talk about anything
you want I just thought I should talk
about business ethics because that was
the nature of the lecture but yeah I'm
very happy to that's what I think thank
you right yep coming coming up there yep
or could you compare just suppose the
ethical dimensions of your presentation
versus the China one belt one Road
initiative yep yep yep yep yep yep yep
yep okay so the China one belt one Road
initiative is an extraordinary
extraordinary thing I mean it's
certainly first in terms of scale so if
you look at the belt and Road initiative
investment in Pakistan the British
Development Agency Pakistan is its
largest single recipient but the British
Development Agency means by that that
they're putting six hundred million
dollars a year into Pakistan the Chinese
belt and Road offer to Pakistan is
valued at 42 billion dollars right I
mean it's a completely different quantum
of involvement it has incredible
implications for climate so that
currently China has about 500 gigawatts
of installed coal-fired generating
capacity but under the belt and Road
initiative there is a proposal already
for nearly 300 gigawatts of additional
coal-fired power for Chinese consumers
powered along the belphin Road and many
of these investments particularly in
relation to places like Myanmar put the
government's concerned in an extremely
uncomfortable position because almost
all of this is soft concessional
financing which puts you into a very
very tricky diplomatic and debt
relationship with the Chinese government
now the opportunity of course for us and
I was talking to the WWF two days ago
about this is what we could do to
partner with the Chinese government to
see whether some of these investments
could be more environmentally friendly
could be undertaken in a way that was
more thoughtful and indeed there is
there is real demand from China for that
China seems to be very interested in
having that kind of conversation but
it's not an easy conversation because as
the British government you would want to
be very careful before you kite marks
the Chinese belt and Road initiative
British development money starts going
in and to try to green the
he's both mert initiative you would not
have any confidence at all that China
couldn't at a moment's notice turn
around and decide they didn't want to do
that and then you were left having
endorsed a project that she would feel
very very exposed on so I think Belton
Road at XI right the way from Myanmar
through Pakistan to Afghanistan is
probably the biggest single example and
indeed in Africa too of foreign direct
investment flows coming in and the
challenges not changes that so thank you
yes yeah you mentioned that the majority
of petitions humours early do you think
there be a similar issue and if there is
how I would be overcome with the British
to partner with private water treatment
companies providing clean water enchant
and making a profit off it with the help
of the British government as opposed to
the more traditional it's unbelievably
politically difficult this stuff so the
British government is already in trouble
because it's putting I mean remember the
money that the British Development
Agency is spending as money that is is
taken forcibly in taxation from British
citizens so effectively you're taking
you know forty five pounds from your
mother
right and then you're taking that money
and we're already in trouble because
we're spending it on helping to
subsidize private schools in Kenya for
example right now the argument for that
is that these are low cost private
schools they provide a very high-quality
education and they're rolled out very
quickly and if your objective is to get
as many children educated as quickly as
possible then you accept low-cost
private education but people are already
pretty uncomfortable at the idea that
we're putting taxpayers money into that
take it to the next level when you start
talking about blended finance right when
I was such as say for International
evelopment my department was already
talking about differed putting money
into listed companies on the
[ __ ] exchange right putting our own risk
capital in to create these investment
vehicles that were then going to invest
in Africa the argument being that the
money in vail abaut for the investment
in Africa you know was a very elusive
way of managing risks so let's say they
have a hundred million and we put in 50
million we take the first tranche risk
which allows them to spend their hundred
million more cheerfully now I personally
vetoed this project because I thought
the British public we're going to get
completely bananas if we start taking
their money and betting it on the London
Stock Exchange right and but sometimes
we have to do this let me give you a
counter example in the other direction
one of the great achievements in Kenya
in the last three years is the building
of 365 wind turbines lake near Lake
Turkana fantastic place to build a wind
turbine generation ideal constant wind
speeds of 12 to 14 miles per hour
the largest single assembly of wind
turbines already generating at night
nearly 30 percent of Kenya's electricity
needs but the closer you get to the
projects the more uncomfortable you feel
and yet you still should be doing it and
this is the tricky thing here when you
stand in Lake Turkana
on the cliff with the guy that's made
that investment and he says to you how's
it working and he says yeah well I mean
this year we're gonna make probably a
hundred and twenty million dollars worth
of profit off this right actually think
it's absolute arable right we're putting
concessional loans into building these
wind turbines this guy's making a
hundred twenty million dollars worth of
but then he says yeah but you got to
understand that this was a very risky
proposition and for the last three years
we've made no money at all because the
Kenyan government didn't build the
transmission lines in the way that we
wanted so we were having to pay for all
our stuff and all I went to UPS our
generation messy so we were losing 40
million dollars a year over the last
three years and yes I got lucky this
year because they finally bought the
generation capacity but then I've got
all this debt that I've got to pay off
so in the end I'm only taking home ten
in dollars a year into my own pocket
right um no only this guy probably
probably or any someone like this guy
was likely to get that project off the
ground he had to essentially build a
road all the way from Mombasa to Lake
Turkana he put himself in the middle of
nowhere one of the most desolate desert
landscapes in northern Kenya he had to
design a new type of wind turbine a
special short wind turbine to get round
73 roundabouts between Mombasa and this
place he had to build roads going all
the way up the coast nobody had ever
built anything else guy had to put up
with the risk of the Kenyan government
and paying the landowners he in order to
get it done he personally sent out 25
people to negotiate with every landowner
between Turkana and Nairobi to get
permission to put the transmission lines
across their land he negotiated the
contracts of how much he needed a page
one of those people he put in a bit of
paper he took it to the Kenyan
government he said for 23 million
dollars you can buy out every land owner
between here in Nairobi this is the map
this is how you do it this is the
contract with every one of them and the
Kenyan government then took that sat on
it for two years and then paid out 75
million dollars instead because they
wanted to give out more to their friends
right so nobody from the DF is nobody
from CDC nobody from the IFRS neighbors
and World Bank wanted to make this
investment in wind turbines alright all
they could see was the political risk
all they could see was the horrid
turbines were never been built unless
this guy was prepared to ride it through
so we have to defend that but it's not
an easy thing to defend when you're
standing up there on the cliff and
you're hearing that he's going to put
ten million dollars in his pocket right
sir
okay so let's let's start with
infrastructure banks so and actually
this this Kenya project is quite a good
route into this this individual tried to
borrow money from the major
infrastructure banks so he tried to
borrow from the IFC which is above World
Bank infrastructure bank he tried to
borrow from CDC which is the British
equivalent he tried to borrow from the
Dutch equivalent so these are banks
which for those who don't understand
them they're given public money and they
are supposed to be able to take risk
that a normal bank can't take and
they're supposed to accept lower
interest rates and they're supposed to
and as a result by by taking more risk
and accepting lower interest rates
they're meant to get projects off the
ground that couldn't be funded by the
private sector but consistently what
seems to happen is that actually these
banks are so risk-averse so in the case
of that particular investment in Kenya
they were demanding that the risk was
wrapped and rewrapped at a cost of an
additional 20 percent to the project
they were charging interest rates a real
interest rates of about eleven and a
half percent to him that he actually
financed the entire thing out of the
private sector and didn't touch a single
one of these development finance
institutions to get the whole thing off
the ground so there is a real problem
actually even when these things have
been funded of getting the money out of
these development finance institutions
into these kind of projects and only
give another example right the other
problem that they face because they're
spending public money is they faced huge
fiduciary risk so CDC invested in a oil
palm plantation Boronia in central
Democratic Republic of the Congo
employing 27,000 people in central DRC
but from the moment they made that
investment which took them nearly four
years to make the investments and it's
200 miles up the Congo River and it's a
very very difficult place to access they
are being assaulted in Parliament day
and day out because investigative
journalists have discovered that the
workers on that primal factory are
complaining that they're not being paid
enough and there's a huge amount of
problem of the land rights and how
exactly ferny a-- got hold of the palm
oil plantations and who the previous now
known as well and cdc isn't able to
shrug that off in the way that a private
investor can shrug that off because this
is public money that they're spending
this way so i think there is potential
in these instruments and I think this
potential CERN in social impact bonds
but often when the rubber hits the road
partly because they're spending public
money they often end up having their
hands tied behind their backs in ways
that makes it very difficult practically
for them to make the investments on the
ground sir yep okay it's a very very
different difficult question okay so for
those who didn't hear the question yeah
question was how do i reconcile
reporting of poverty in my constituency
okay my own reporting of poverty in my
constituency and he's put he's produced
to quite hear about my saying that some
of the constituents my constituents hold
their trousers up with twine against the
government's record on austerity so I
suppose were two questions I mean is
this a sincere question that you want an
answer to or is it a political point
that you're making okay well so the
sincere answer to that is that my
comment about constituents holding their
trousers up with twine Mike so my
constituents hold their trousers up with
twine I mean that's simply a fact right
and if you've spent time in Cumbria most
of my okay right you will have met many
farmers who hold their trousers are
between that's not a secret
it's very common i myself hope i dress
this up with twine on the bigger
question of poverty indicators in the
constituency so my constituency is a
royal constituency the average incomes
of my constituency are about 16,000
pounds each
Yeah right which puts nearly 60% of my
constituents within a the national
definitions of poverty right that's in
relation to the median income at the
same time unemployment rates in my
constituency are the 10th lowest in the
country so out of the entire
constituency there are currently
approximately 54 people on long-term
unemployment benefit out of the entire
constituency so it's a very very
unusually structured place you know very
low incomes very high employment a very
very high number of self-employed people
so nearly 29 percent of my constituents
are self-employed 92% work for
businesses employing less than 10
by contrast the West of Cumbria
right so the area around Sellafield has
higher incomes on average lower poverty
reporting but much much higher
unemployment much higher issues with a
addiction much more serious issues with
addiction much more serious issues with
family breakdown which is why I think
that my conclusion in Britain is that
the indicators that really matter are
not primarily median income indicators
so a Hartlepool for example where I was
three weeks ago
you are looking at communities near
hardly poor easing tenoram 'pl
essentially for the entire community in
Islington is unemployed where people are
the whole southern half of easing ttan
house after house are people who are
heroin addicts you are looking at I was
with a family and Hartlepool where I
discovered the twelve-year-old child
being killed by a car two months earlier
where the woman's latest grandson had
died prematurely where the third
granddaughter had been born
had been born deaf this is partly
related to the fact that they're smoking
a lot the man that I was with was
drinking 12 bottles three litre bottles
of cider a day I'm in a kind of
phenomenal amount there are serious
mental health issues huge addiction
issues and they're the biggest problem
is not universal credit he's not on
universal credit he's on disability
benefit the biggest issues are cuts to
mental health treatments to addiction
treatment to youth workers so for from
my point of view the damage of austerity
is not a median poverty the damage of
authority is generally on the support
services and if I was spending money I
wouldn't be directing it in the first
instance towards my constituency I would
be directing it towards communities such
as that community needs it right yeah so
thank you
yeah I mean I think your second point is
actually right when these one belt one
Road initiatives are financed by the
Asian Development Act is absolutely no
difference from the thing finite being
financed by the World Bank I mean the
difference in the one belt one Road
initiatives of course is that they're
often a very direct Chinese concessional
financing there's often very direct
Chinese companies involved Chinese labor
involved so one of the issues if you're
Myanmar looking at a port is how much
benefit actually is Burma really going
to drive from this project or is this
simply a fully Chinese controlled owned
managed constructed enterprise where the
benefit seems to accrue more directly to
China let me take two questions together
well that's a yes
is the so I I think that I mean this is
you know this is moving well beyond a
Mars lecture on on business and
international development but yeah I
mean if I try to take seriously that
that question for a moment
I think the Aristotle's
framework for thinking about ethics and
politics seems to me a very very useful
way of trying to think about what it
means to engage with the world and
change the world in a whole series of
different ways but the first thing that
I think is most striking about
Aristotle's insight is the connection
between practical wisdom courage and
reality right and this is relevant if
you want to think about Donald Trump or
you want to think about Boris or indeed
if you want to think about people on the
left as well as the right okay the point
being this that what our subtle points
out is that for him courage is the
intermediate point between full
hardiness and cowardice and it is the
intermediate point because what makes
somebody foolhardy is that they're
living in a fairy story world they don't
actually understand reality
superficially the brave person on the
foolhardy person seems similar right
they're both risking pain they're both
risking their lives but the foolhardy
person doesn't understand where they are
doesn't understand the risk that they're
running it is making no attempt to
adjust to the conditions so to put it in
very direct military terms the foolhardy
person is walking directly across the
field to the machine gun the courageous
person is working their way along a
hedgerow and trying to avoid being shot
by the machine gun and still trying to
get across the field but they're more
likely to make it across the field now
why is this important this is important
because if earth Explorer election and
politics derives from reality we can
demand of Boris or of Donald Trump that
they describe reality that they do not
offer fairy stories that it's not good
enough to avoid the question how I mean
the interesting thing in politics in the
United States and in Britain indeed for
almost all successful politicians in
both countries is that nobody talks
about how right all the money goes to
person who sounds boldest most radical
most optimistic right it's as though in
your domestic life I was sitting with
you and I was saying next year we're
gonna move to Mauritius and we're gonna
buy a 20 million dollar house I'm gonna
live there for 10 years right and you're
gonna say to me how right you're out of
your mind are you gonna do this you
can't do this and ridiculous right but
in politics ah you say that everyone's
like ah fantastic right this guy knows
where he's going he's got a great bold
vision right okay no in the nature of
contemporary politics and this is as
true for some of the current canit's
Democratic Party it's is true of Jeremy
Corbyn as it is of Boris Johnson or
Donald Trump right people are really
reveling in the ability to create these
kinds of fairy stories it's somehow
least they know what they want least
they know what they stand for least
they're confident at least they're clear
right and it doesn't seem possible to
say that this confidence and clarity is
like me saying I'm going to Mars and
everyone's like are fantastic he's
confident he's clear he knows where he's
going right nobody's able to say conquer
tomorrow so I think that part of our
stato is really important but there's
more to it than that right which is that
the Aristotelian framework is is
thankfully saying that there is no grand
theory to this but this isn't about
jargon this isn't about grand statements
about equality or sustainability or to
challenge you poverty right it's not
about just putting up a word it's about
the exact you know the reason why when
you ask me about poverty I want to
answer you in terms of this place its
income its employment statistics and
this place in Hartlepool right is that
the word poverty removed from context
can convey 2,000 different things to
2,000 different people it stretches all
the way from my constituency to Calcutta
right from Hartlepool to France I mean
it doesn't help
you really understand what's happening
in someone's life and above all it
doesn't help you understand how to solve
it right the only way that you can
actually make the world better change
the world is understand its specificity
and so I think it's that part of our
städel the notion of practical wisdom
located in a place at a time you know
what you can do rather than what you
ought to do that's the key to politics
yeah I don't think he's gonna I mean
ride on it
I mean obviously I've just I've votes it
against the know do Bret said I've now
been thrown out of the Conservative
Party I'm effectively lost my job so
I've made this bet that what I did was
worthwhile right I'm assuming that I
have successfully prevented an ad or
brexit and that we will have an
extension through January I mean
goodness knows what we're gonna do with
the extension through charity but at
least we've avoided a No Deal Bret since
that first walk today he's saying that
he will ignore this but I think we have
many many ways rounds we can directly go
from Parliament Europe we can instruct
an ambassador we can instruct a cabinet
secretary my expectation is he will sulk
he will refuse to do it
nevertheless the requests will be made
the extension will be granted and then
he will try to go into an election
saying it was over my dead body I didn't
want it to happen people against the
Parliament and try to win a majority for
an idea brexit arguing that he was
frustrated by us but I don't think we
will crash out on the 31st of October I
think you'll find it very difficult to
do
sort of undesirable collateral costs so
to kind of flip it when you're when
you're kind of putting together this
package all these different directions I
sometimes think about is the sort of
undesirable influence of effective
altruism as a kind of influence that
steers things towards what's going to
rather than yeah and I think that's a
really really really good challenge and
I don't have an easy answer to that but
I think your fundamental observation
must be right I mean in the end the
private sector is motivated primarily by
profit and there is always likely to be
a gap between the objectives of the
private sector and the sustainable
development objectives that you have in
a particular country and I think there
is a danger always implicit in imagining
that you can achieve your ethical
objective through convincing the company
instrumentally that they're going to
make more money by behaving ethically
because it all it's always available to
that individual to then turn around and
say well actually thank you very much
for that lovely suggestion that I'm
going to make more money by acting
ethically but I've discovered a lovely
way of making money where I don't need
to act ethically so thank you for your
lovely advice and actually I found that
that that if I chuck all my chemicals
into the river that is actually much
much cheaper than than pumping them out
into some other place so I think
[Music]
everything in the
and the trick is to try to harness the
private sector when it's appropriate to
do so understand there are some things
that the private sector does better than
the public sector I mean there's there's
no doubt I mean if you look at the
Special Inspector General of Afghanistan
to report on the USAID program on trying
to create private sector jobs
the Development Agency spent a hundred
and sixty three million dollars I think
trying to create jobs in Afghanistan
right so it's a government agency trying
to do it at the end of the whole process
seiga concludes that they may have
created six jobs but they're unable to
actually validate if even those six jobs
exist right now the private sector
generally in making an investment is
more likely than the government to try
to check that there really is a market
for the goods they're producing that the
jobs they're creating may actually be
sustained through a viable business and
so I think if you're trying to do
something like generate employment right
I think it makes sense to believe that
most of the jobs that are going to be
created in Africa are likely to be
created through the private sector but
if what you're trying to do is talk
about values that go beyond the
generating a generation of employment
then then I think the private sector
needs to be balanced by a whole series
of other types of investments
regulations constraints
yeah I mean so that the British that the
Britain is in a real problem at the
moment as you might have noticed and we
are performing a basic public service
which is that I discovered that really
what we've done for the world is to give
the United States an opportunity to feel
better about themselves by its it's a
it's a real it's a real achievement
everyone's really cheered up they're
like ah it's great we thought we were
the the worst straight um one of the
biggest problems that we face is in
relation to our Constitution so I mean
of course every system depends on
unwritten rules and codes of conduct and
ways of behaving but in Britain it's
even more extreme things are so
uncodified that the Prime Minister is
currently doing things and the speak for
the House of Commons currently doing
things that are never been tried before
that we're always theoretically possible
but nobody considered doing them I'm
just to give some very quick examples
the premise that I mean getting rid of
me and twenty one of my colleagues it's
completely unprecedented I mean
essentially what he's saying is that if
a member of parliament votes once
against the executive that's it they've
lost their job and it will be like Trump
suggesting that if a single Republican
congressman voted in a single vote in
Congress against him he would attempt to
engineer from the center there
deselection from whichever congressional
seat they represented to ensure they can
never run again right he has proved
Parliament in order to try to prevent
Parliament stopping an OD or brexit and
it's suspended the legislators are
prevented from expressing its opinion
but on the other hand the speaker is
doing similar things I mean I voted in
to do something that was pretty close to
being illegal two months ago right the
way I was able to stop an OD over X said
is that the speaker allowed us to take
control of the order paper from the
government by changing this s 824 motion
which isn't meant to have a positive
motion allowed or put a positive motion
on it which we've then voted three to
track him right so the entire system is
lurching around we don't even have rules
there
a referendum we don't know what a
referendum really is in our country in
the 1970s when Scotland wanted to vote
for devolution they were required to
achieve a supermajority they weren't
allowed to do it on a 50 plus one basis
now suddenly we're running referendums
on a 50 plus one basis
now the people campaigning for a second
referendum is saying well if we do a
second referendum on brexit instead of
the last referendum we're only 18
year-olds come vote 16 year-olds
conveyed in the next referendum and in
fenton the Scottish referendum 16 year
olds were motivated but in the brexit
referendum 18 year olds for a lot of it
I mean especially the whole thing is
just a complete mess of people making it
up as they go along so we need a written
constitution to protect the people
against parliament and against the
executive I mean these people are and
under the reason for this is that of
course you can always get a constituency
for this I mean basically all that most
people seem to care about is the outcome
they don't care about the process at all
so you notice for example that notice
that people who voted remain point out
enormous process problems with a
referendum there was dodgy money
the relies on the side of a bus it was
only an advisory referendum anybody who
voted brexit none of them complain about
the process the referendum whatsoever
again anyone who voted Breck said is
perfectly comfortable with the
prorogation of Parliament anybody who
like me right
once the stop and rodeo breaks it is
enraged by the progression in Parliament
but not but it's a mistake to imagine
that's because any of us have any real
commitment to the constitutional
principles at stake it's simply that we
want to get our way and the whole thing
is coming sure the way so people are
egging Boris on I mean he's not if he
refuses to accept the Supreme Court
ruling
many many of his core vote will be like
good on it because they voted for him as
I think or many people voted for him in
the way that people may have voted for
Trump which is that he's that she
intended to be a sort of hand grenade
that they're throwing at the entire
system the idea is that I and other
people like
we are kind of out of touch elite stuck
in this funny little pyramid we don't
really understand the real thing
government isn't working for people it's
not moving so what do you do you get
Jeremy Corbyn or you get Boris and you
chuck this Hagrid straight out of the
thing and if you say to people who are
voting for him but who is this guy I
mean why do you think he's gonna be a
good premise so that's not really the
question they're asking themselves they
trust the fact that he's gonna be a
ruffian it's gonna shake it up right
he's gonna show these people he's gonna
tear up this kind of cosy elite
establishment consensus so we need a
written constitution general up there in
the yellow t-shirt yep so I I mean let
me finish on this then
so I leave there is a potential to be a
trumpian anti-trump I believe there is a
viable for the sake of argument radical
Center ground of politics right but the
only way of thinking about it is to
think about it not as a as a bland
midpoint between two extremes right this
is why the center always fails
everybody always thinks about the center
as though it's a sort of refusal to make
a decision I don't know splitting the
difference and it becomes very jargon
filled I mean actually a lot of these
words you know that we're on that sheet
when I began all these words like
sustainability or kind of a classic
centrist words because they feel like a
sort of bland justification of the
status quo what we have to do is get
back from Aristotle to Heraclitus and
take the fundamental insight there and
in the fundamental inside of Heraclitus
is that actually the power of the center
ground lies in the tension between the
two extremes so the center ground
shouldn't be the midpoint on this stick
it should be instead
bringing a string from the top to the
bottom and turning it into a bow so that
the center point draws right on the
tension between right and left I mean it
might combine some of the inherent
energy of the individualism of one the
compassion of the other the patriotism
of the one the moral project to the
other and draw from that something that
actually includes the whole of society
man it really the problem with these
projects of Corbin or Boras are that
they are divisive right people are
reveling in us against them all right
the reason I can't get any compromise on
brexit despite the fact that a
compromise on brexit is the obvious
thing to do right people voted for
brexit by a narrow margin 52:48 let's
have a 52:48 brexit let's look at
something between Switzerland and Turkey
let's remain close to the European Union
economically let's leave the political
institutions right let's get on with it
right nobody wants this right
everybody's either like bah
rubbish no breaks that at all or they're
like we want the hardest No Deal brexit
and the problem is that they really do
not want to even think about how much
they have in common they don't even want
to have a conversation about because
they don't recognize themselves in the
other they love the sense that they're
different to these other people in fact
the entire brexit debate is bizarre
right the reason I fail on getting a
compromise is I keep suggesting that
it's about a technical discussion about
what kind of tariff levels you want or
what kind of relationship you're on the
European it's not that at all or if
you've got one side saying make Britain
great again and you've got another side
saying oh the brexit voters are ignorant
racist nationalists and we should listen
to them in other words one side is
making some comment about Britain
another side is making a comment about
the brakes of voters but neither of them
are making any comment whatsoever about
what a practical relationship with the
European Union might be so it's almost
impossible to get any kind of compromise
going against so to return right I'm not
voting for either of these people right
I am trying to pull back towards this
and what I like about this is it's an
attempt to include the entire community
of our nation rather than split one
against the other and
find that energy by combining it and
from the tension between the two thank
you all very much indeed and good night
[Applause]
[Music]